[Music]
I've never been so nervous for a video
with my hi I'm Hannah and then the
world's okay it's mom and the number one
question I'm asked wait give it hi I'm
Hannah and I'm the world's okay it's mom
now the number one question that you
guys asked me is am I ever going to have
a third child and the second most asked
question is am I ever going to change my
hair color and if so what color would I
change it to now I have no idea what
color I would go to from this blue
because I've had it blue for so long but
one thing's for sure is I want to
involve the boys in it somehow so I
figured let's do something totally crazy
I'm gonna let the boys give me a full
makeover now I have no idea how this is
gonna go I have no idea what's gonna
happen but wish me luck
so first let's define what this makeover
is it's not only going to include my
hair color but the boys will also choose
my haircut and my outfit and I'm gonna
have to you need to stop harassing me
for pets you need to stop harassing me
for pets okay I pet you all day the boys
are going to choose my new hair color
haircuts and outfit they're not gonna do
my makeup we did a whole week of them
doing my makeup you can watch that video
so I need to establish a few ground
rules for this makeover at first because
my hair is still a little bit blue there
are some colors that are just off the
table for example no pastel pink so
we're gonna offer the boys a range of
colors that we can do in one treatment
it's a little more limited but there are
still lots of options for them to choose
from second I'm going to offer the boys
some hairstyles that they can choose
from I know my boys I know the first
thing they're gonna try to pick is a
mohawk and I'm just not gonna do that no
shame
Ted no mohawk no nonsense like that so
like the color I'm gonna give them
several options just none that are
completely implausible I'm extremely
nervous for this change the blue hair is
my thing
you guys know this I've had it for over
two years and it's just I feel like this
is my natural hair color and it just
means so much to me that I'm afraid to
lose it I can't believe that I'm gonna
do this tomorrow hi I'm Cherie I'm a
hair stylist at the butterfly loft salon
new bungalows when Hannah told me that
she was gonna let her kids choose her
cut in her color my first thought was oh
no okay I'm gonna leave the room make a
good choice okay
pick something good promise okay all
right guys we're gonna choose the color
of mommy's hair you guys ready why you
ready all right let's do it
all right let's take a look at the
colors what do we got
so I'd actually be really open to silver
or gray but hands down my number one
choice if I were to change my hair color
is purple what do you think oh yeah
that's cool
you like silver
magenta and sober you like that too
hey guys you ready to choose the haircut
for mommy hope they don't choose which
ones do you like okay between these two
which one do you think point at it so
when it came time to pick a cut in a
color the boys picked magenta is the
color and they picked a short layer cut
for the haircut once we decided on the
cut in the color we brought Hanna in and
we started with a haircut the reason for
that is if we're cutting a lot of hair
off we don't want to take all the time
to process all that hair just to hack it
off in the end so we had Doug come in my
good friend Doug and he did her haircut
for us you ready for me to cut your hair
off yes all right I'm so ready my name
is Doug Theo Harris I work here at
butterfly loft salon and I am a platform
artist and educator for pulp riot I've
seen a lot of Doug's haircuts and
they're all fantastic so I'm just really
really excited that I get to have one
from him that's awesome I'm excited dude
when I heard that the kids are gonna
choose the haircut the color I was
really intrigued because I have a
daughter who's the same age as her
oldest son so I could only imagine what
she would want to do to my hair that's
the first thing Jackson said when I was
like you get to pick the cut he's like
I'm gonna make you bald so they picked a
short layered haircut and honestly that
it couldn't be more on trend
it's the look those are the types of
haircuts that I'm doing in the salon all
the time right now it feels like and I
know he's not doing it but it feels like
the hair is being cut like two inches
from my scalp curtain Oh
her hair's perfect for a cut like this
because she's got a lot of hair it's
kind of on the fine side so you can kind
of manipulate it and get it to do like
whatever you want it to do this feels
very short I'm trying really hard not to
peak right now I feel like she held it
together pretty much while I was cutting
her hair I know when she saw that pile
of hair on the floor wow I was not
expecting to see that much wow that
looks like a rat's nest alright guys my
job's done I feel good I'm excited it
feels very different alright guys so
let's get going we're gonna go get mommy
some clothes right yeah Wyatt what do
you want to get her you want a dress
yeah I think a dress a solid choice what
color why yeah alright you guys ready to
go let's go do it
yeah all right let's go all right so
what's going on right now is Hannah has
a ton of her natural color so we got a
bleach that out so what we're doing is
we're lightening it but we're kind of
doing like a modified balayage which we
sometimes call a foil wash I bet Jackson
chose pink I bet he suede Wyatt to
choose pink he's been talking about me
having pink hair for a while I don't
know if pink is my best look continue
but I don't know right now we're toning
he and his hair was really blue so it
comes out green you can't get blue out
all the way so it's really hard usually
for people that change colors from blue
so I haven't even thought about this I
wonder how the boys are doing with their
shopping in TEVAR
right now alright so we just got our
clothes how do you feel about what we
got Jackson literally get it um I'm a
little worried about the outfit I just
hope I'm fully clothed and I think at
the very least they will choose clothes
that
they would want to wear because they
don't quite grasp the idea of shopping
for somebody else what you happier than
what you got for Mama all right so now
that we've toned her hair we're putting
on her main color and then we're gonna
leave some pieces out giving it away
we're gonna leave some pieces out using
a clear well I know it's two colors so I
just really hope it's nothing in that
clashes I think what I need to do is
stop trying to figure out what it is
before I agree it because I'm driving
myself nuts and I think I'm driving
everyone in the room nuts and at that
point I was really getting in my head I
was really freaking out so I texted my
friend Joey looks so good oh my gosh
Hugh right off the bat how are you
feeling I'm excited well if you say it's
okay
yeah I feel better no I think that
you'll rock this color for sure because
you've had so many colors yeah I've gone
through them all the only clothes I
haven't done our orange and red any
yellow when you first changed colors how
was that it was alarming you're so used
to seeing yourself a certain way that
the initial shock but then I totally got
used to it and I like eventually love
that color but it's definitely a shock
at first yeah
so should we expect some tears happening
not in front of you know your peers so
that means I can't cry rinsing it out
and the boys brought their outfit back
so I'm going to put the outfit on while
my hair is still wet and rest in a towel
and then we'll dry it out and I can
finally see it beautifully
yes I think Jackson probably picked the
pants and Wyatt picks the top hopefully
so the last thing shredded was style my
hair and then it was time for the big
reveal and I was so nervous
oh my god
what what I'm like shaking right now
oh my I think I went into shock for a
second cuz I look like a different
person job like from here I would have
no idea that's me I love it
I feel like I needed a big change and
this is a really good big change thank
you so much I love you so I know the
boys are gonna freak out
I know Matt is probably gonna freak out
the most because I straight-up
look like I'm a different person right
now I don't think Rosie will recognize
me she might recognize my voice
but she's gonna be like who's this in my
house
alright I am walking in the door to show
the boys so let's see what they think
you big Shorthair and who picked magenta
me now what do you think I like it did
it take some getting used to you're
right on a scale of 1 to 10 what do you
think of your choice 1 to 10 how much do
you like the new hair 10 so what did I
learn well this was a fun thing to try
with the kids and it was a cute
experience will I keep this hair no
because I've learned that blue is such a
huge part of my identity the blue hair
is what makes me happy but that being
said if you want to try a bold color or
even this color I'd highly recommend it
because you'll learn a lot about
yourself and you'll see what you really
like but maybe you don't let your kids
pick it without you knowing so that's
why I got for this season I'm Hannah and
exciting news we have a merch for the
show now join my mana squad you don't
even have to be a mom to join now if
there's anything you want to see you
next season leave it in the comments
because a lot of these episodes from
this season were requested by you guys
or you can always text me this is a real
number I don't answer all of them
because I get a lot but I do read every
single one so if you'll please excuse me
I'm going to relax on my couch in an
outfit that I chose for myself so next
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you